I don't Lee I mean there is that there
is there is a there is a common
differentiation that that you know
leadership is though is the why and the
where and management is the how and it
is sort of a sort of a lower a lower art
but I actually think it's a distinction
without a difference in an important
kind of way I think there is an element
that you know bosses senior people have
that is a leadership element since we've
got to decide where we're going to go
and what this is all about and we've got
to try to make meaning and make sense of
things and and sort of an inspirational
role that role doesn't necessarily have
to be held by somebody who's the chief
person in the hierarchy to you know the
leader can alter is it there's a there's
that leadership role can be taken by
anybody at any time what I think of you
know in this leadership management
distinction management becomes a lesser
art you know it's its leadership as
poetry and management is prose I I think
there's a lot of poetry and prose what I
think about it and this is the this is
something that I've only come to
recently but but it motivates me
strongly is this idea that you spend we
spend people who work in organizations
spend at least a third of their waking
hours at work they get most of their
training and education after school
after they leave school happens at work
they you know their relationship to
their workplace is the most important
work relationship they have except for
that in that to their families and in
some cases it's more important so
there's a moral dimension to this I mean
the decisions that managers make about
whom to promote or who not to promote or
the decisions that the seemingly little
decisions managers make about how to
whether to treat people rudely or or
kindly our decisions with kind of large
moral consequences for the for
themselves and for the individuals are
them and so I really think it's a false
distinction I I think that this in this
you know pros of management there is a
pretty important stuff